your brother has been dealing with dermatographia, skid writing, and itching all over for two years.
The itchy is mainly torso, back, and head. Sometimes his legs never palms or feet. He's
currently taken over the counter, um, uh, bent out in front of the toys. We take it over three days.
So really, this is really not, um, the avenue to ask questions about your brother,
so your brother should really make an appointment with me, um, and we should go from there.
So, um, there's just too many things going on.
Dramatic graphia is very common with line disease, chronic lab disease. That's the first thing you
can think of with this. So, but it's, you know, because it's so much, um, so common in the line
community that that is an issue. But the truth is, any, um, inflammation, any inflammatory
skin disorder, which can be a host of different antibodies that you can develop to your muscles and
your skin, uh, can be a cause of this. So doing antibody testing would be the way to go with this.
So, so we're going to, uh, there's a little, uh, that's the right thing.